-Nikolaj, it is great
to see you again.
-Great to see you.
-I was going to ask you this
because we were
talking backstage.
You've been around the world
in like the last couple weeks.
Do you have any idea
where you are right now?
[ Laughter ]
-I'm in sunny New York.
-Yeah, sunny -- [ Laughs ]
-What a beautiful day.
-Sunny New York, yeah.
-I know.
-How was the travels?
-It's been a challenge.
It's been so much fun.
I'm doing this show.
We're traveling.
I've been to Africa,
North America, Asia,
and Australia.
And Australia, you know...
-Gorgeous.
-...beautiful place.
The only thing,
of course, is that
everything will kill you
or hurt you.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, no, I'm a little afraid of,
yeah, because, yeah, if you swim
in the ocean, sharks.
-I was swimming
in the Great Barrier Reef
and, of course, then you look
down, there is a shark,
which, they keep telling you,
it's fine.
[ Laughter ]
And then you read the news
and someone was --
No, it's not fine.
-No, that's not fine.
What are you talking about?
Yeah, yeah.
You have something
that happened to you.
-Oh, yeah, no, because I was
being so cautious
with everything,
but I got bitten
by these mosquitoes.
And mosquitoes like, you know,
it's fine.
-Of course.
-And, you know, it reacted.
It got kind of big, but I was
like, "Okay, it's fine."
We kept traveling.
We went to Vietnam.
It got worse, and then these
blisters started forming
[ Ewws ]
and it got even -- Yeah,
[ Laughter ]
it's disgusting.
And then I was going to Japan
and, on the flight there,
it started oozing like --
[ Ewws ]
Yeah, I'm sorry.
[ Laughter ]
But really, like, literally,
it's like I was peeing my knees
or something.
[ Ewws ]
I don't know how to explain it.
-You just did.
[ Laughter ]
We get it. We get it.
We get it, yeah.
-Anyway, I make it to Japan
and a place called Takeshima
and I say, "I think
I should see a doctor."
-Something's wrong, yeah.
-So we found,
went to this place, this doctor.
I mean,
even in the waiting room,
there's a kid walked past,
looked at my knees like, "Oh!"
[ Laughter ]
With tears in his eyes.
So, I come in,
but then this doctor,
she looks at my knee
and she goes -- [ Gasping ]
And then she found these books
to show me these pictures
and there was like
all these disgusting images
and she's like, "It's like this.
Worse.
Yours is worse."
[ Laughter ]
-Wow!
-Yeah, it was disgusting.
-Doctor says that, yeah.
And you don't speak
any Japanese?
-I do not, no.
I had a translator
and then she was helping me out.
And then this other nurse --
all these nurses
suddenly appeared
and they started treating
my legs
and they were kind of
wrapping it
and like I looked like
"The Mummy."
And it worked.
I felt good. I felt safe.
-You did?
-I did.
[ Laughter ]
-You actually brought us
a photo, which I...
-Oh, yes.
-...want to show everyone.
This is your knee
all wrapped up.
Look at how happy
these women are.
[ Laughter ]
-I know.
-They're so happy
to have you in the hospital.
Like, "Hey, I'll treat him!"
[ Laughter ]
"No, no I'll treat him!
I'll rub his legs!"
"Let me rub his legs.
No, let me rub his back."
They go, oh, yeah.
They're so psyched.
-And they really saved me.
They saved the trip.
I'm so grateful.
So, if they watch this,
thank you so much.
-Yeah. Come on.
-Yes.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-I want to talk about this
new series on Apple TV+.
You and Jennifer Garner.
-Amazing.
-Come on.
[ Cheering and applause ]
That's all I need to know.
It's called
"The Last Thing He Told Me"
and it is part mystery,
part thriller, part love story.
I don't want to give anything,
really, away, but --
-No, that's about it, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-"The Last Thing He Told Me."
And...
from what we know, is,
happily married,
have a teenage daughter.
All of a sudden,
you're not there.
-Yeah.
-And there's a note from you.
-It says, "Protect her."
-That's it.
-There you go.
-And then you have to find out.
Then they find out
what happened.
Who is this guy?
-Did you die?
[ Laughter ]
We don't know.
-No, I mean,
it's just a mystery.
-I don't know.
You guys had good chemistry.
Have you known each other
for a while?
-No, no, I'd never met
Jennifer before
and it was kind of a --
[ Laughs ]
It was the weirdest
first meeting
I've ever had on a movie,
or a show.
I'd met the director
and the producer
and they said, "Okay, tomorrow
you're going to meet Jennifer
and you're going to have
a session
with an intimacy coach."
And I was like --
-Intimacy coach?
-Intimacy coach.
Which, usually --
It's a fairly new thing,
but you only do it
if you have like, you know,
like really intimate scenes,
like f--
-A sex scene.
-Yeah, a sex scene.
[ Laughter ]
You almost said it.
-I almost said it, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Thank you.
-And I was like,
"Did they rewrite the script?"
Because I hadn't seen any
of those.
-There's nothing that raunchy.
-No, no, no, no.
But anyway, so, and I'm like,
"Oh, this is going
to be uncomfortable.
Like the first time I meet her,
are we going to be...?"
But maybe, I thought,
it was something she requested?
[ Laughter ]
-You're right.
You're right. You're right.
-No, I didn't know.
-You never know.
You're a gentleman.
-I show up next day
at her house...
-Oh, yeah.
-...with the director and this
very sensual intimacy coach.
[ Laughter ]
And we go into this room.
-The coach is sensual?
-She was very -- I mean...
-Intimate?
[ Laughter ]
-Yes!
But also very much grounded
in her body.
-Wow!
-So, the first time
we really meet is
she tells us, "Now, you stand
up, get really close."
And then you have to get really,
really close
with a person you don't know
and then close your eyes.
"And now smell each other."
[ Laughter ]
And we smell and --
-What?!
-Yes. So we --
[ Sniffing ]
-That's more disturbing...
-We had to smell each --
-...than doing a sex scene,
I think.
[ Laughter ]
-I don't know what kind
of sex scenes you do, but --
[ Laughter ]
-I've never been asked.
Never been asked, yeah.
I could draw you a picture
of what I've --
[ Laughter ]
-Hey.
No, but it was --
But the funny thing,
the good thing about it was,
in that moment, we realized
we had the same sense of humor
because we both started laughing
and we realized,
"Okay, we're serious about this,
but we don't take it
too seriously."
And it was actually
the perfect way to start --
-Break the ice and be, yeah.
-Yeah, to break the ice.
Because you realize
there was no ice to break.
It was just perfect.
-Yeah, it was just being fun.
And, yeah, so we set it up.
There's nothing else.
I don't want to spoil anything.
Are we allowed
to say anything else?
Is there anything you want --
should I say?
-Well, I mean, Jennifer is
incredible in the show
and, no, that's it.
The guy disappears
and you're going to find out.
I don't believe anyone
will be able to guess it.
Unless they read the amazing
book that it's based on.
[ Laughter ]
There is that.
-That's the only other way.
There is that, yeah.
-There is no other thing.
-I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Nikolaj Coster-Waldau
and Jennifer Garner
in "The Last Thing He Told Me."
Take a look.
-Your first lesson is
that a good piece of wood
always has one thing,
one quality, that defines it.
-What defines this piece?
-Oh.
I think this part
could turn out interesting.
-I like that.
-Hm.
-You could probably say
the same thing
about most people --
at the end of the day...
...one thing defines them.
-What defines you?
-I asked first.
[ Suspenseful music plays ]
-There's nothing I wouldn't do
for my daughter.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Yeah, come on.
Nikolaj Coster-Waldau!
"The Last Thing He Told Me"
is streaming now on Apple TV+.
New episodes every Friday.
We'll be right back
with more "Tonight Show."
Stick around, everybody.